[Music]
well hey Marlon I wish for people in
Hong Kong Taiwan and China to tolerate
different values governments should
sincerely respect different political
beliefs and systems pulling Seng up and
tong it's a toll for my good things here
lately
I hope Hong Kong will become more
diverse Hong Kong has always been called
a cultural desert because we focused on
economic development we young people
should show Hong Kong's cultural
uniqueness to the world having lived
outside of eleven on for the past ten
years it makes it difficult for us to
look at our country struggles and being
at a distance my only wish for the next
decade is for us to be able to move back
here to this country our country and to
be able to raise our children here and
be close to our parents and loved ones
for this coming decade I wish for the
Lebanese people to wake up and become
aware that their religious and political
affiliations will lead them nowhere and
will never be and will never build a
country
[Music]
this year hope there will be less racism
in Russia and that minorities will be
your priceless especially when it comes
to the LGBT community and to women I
would like glad Amir Putin to step down
he's been in power for over 18 years and
I'm tired of I want change for Russia
[Music]
country is going to be more prosperous
and I really wish our governments we
really take the government seriously
like put the need of the people before
themselves good governance and good
economic growth and I hope you get out
of poverty soon for more people to take
an interest in politics more cohesion
Bess we are lead no I wish for peace and
prosperity and that we get along with
our neighbors in a pond good o'clock so
then so I'd like for a united Europe
United Britain and we look after each
other and love each other I just want a
younger people I feel like a lot of the
older people get more privileges and
better everything and younger people
deserve a better life as a what I wish
for Venezuela is that we move forward
with the understanding that a country
thrives on work enthusiasm and strength
I wish that Venezuela will become
financially stable and that those who
have left the country can come home
[Music]
well I wish we'd stop fighting we'd come
together we respect one another and
realize that we have more in common than
we have that separates us nothing in the
next decade the United States should
really focus on the people and really
the benefits that we have as citizens
here but also allow allowing immigrants
to enter the country as equal because
that's what we're all about